what's just some read about this this do
to get shot and chop on yeah let's get
into it I gotta say I really don't like
that they call it chop and I you know
what I refuse I also won't yes I won't
call it Willis Tower either Sears now
it's the Sears Tower yes I'm with you
bro the Sears Tower man yeah I what is
Willis Willis Tower now it's the Sears
Tower I have a little thing it says
Sears Tower on it when I went there and
looked down in school I was like what
Sears is like not a company so we're
talking about you guys know Chicago they
got the Sears Tower he might not they
changed the name to Willis Tower I don't
know if you know this Tim is from
Chicago oh okay that's right yeah that
was a growing up at a war zone I'm only
half kidding but what I funny enough I'm
actually also from Chicago I was born in
the city and Lake Shore Drive and yeah
we we didn't know each other until later
on in life but must be a Chicago thing
we get along you know we were like hey I
think that was the first thing he said
to me hey you from Chicago
no all right check us out check us out I
got local Fox teen shot in Seattle's
chopped is declining to do a police
interview and this is this is this is
what they're all about they have that
they have like this rule where you can't
talk to the police
yeah so there you go here's the latest
report so I don't know if you guys heard
two days ago not even two days ago we
had two shootings and and I mentioned
this earlier guy gets out of an SUV
reportedly with a rifle shoot somebody
and kills him they blocked the police
from getting in yep
the medics who showed up they were like
that well the medics wouldn't come in so
they were yelling at the medics in the
medics are like no cops no no safe you
know is it you know so now we have this
story check it out for the second time
in less than 48 hours there was a
shooting in Seattle's occupied protest
zone but a 17 year old victim declined
to speak with the detectives
leaving the circumstances of the
shooting unclear police said Monday
video has emerged oh really
a fight broke out okay and then
everyone's trying to break it up and
they're fighting and then all of a
sudden like the next clip is pop pop pop
pop pop do get shot they pick and choose
their battles between what they when
they want the help and when they don't
want to help oh of course they won't
have their cake and eat it too yeah
the story says the shooting happened
late Sunday night in the area known as
chop for Capitol Hill or occupied
protests see they don't even know that
what it means is it organized is it
occupies nobody knows it's not chop it's
chess it's Jeff it's chess think about
this if it was an autonomous zone who
conquered it to make it organized was it
repatriated by America they came back in
and took it back yeah it's no longer
autonomous as with the with a 2:00 a.m.
shooting in the same Park Saturday left
a 19-year old man dead and a 33 year old
man critically injured responding police
and emergency Medicaid at the edge of
the protest zone before going in and
again volunteer medics inside the zone
brought the victim to the hospital in a
private car rather than wait for the
police or fire departments I mean that I
look I'm not gonna pretend to know what
you should do maybe you should rush
someone to the hospital if you can yeah
instead just sit around waiting maybe
maybe the EMTs or be better because the
ambulance is gonna have you know tools
and medical kits and stuff yeah might be
able to stop the bleeding to ensure the
safety of medical personnel police stage
with Seattle Fire at the edge of the
chop area and were gathering information
about where the shooting victim was
located when they learned he had been
transported in a private vehicle blah
blah blah the 17 year old was treated
and released and declined to speak with
detectives the department said
investigators asked anyone with
information about the shooting to come
forward so this is the chaos right in
response to this chopped members Chaz
members proposed changes to protest zone
including curfew safe few sites after
violent weekend these poor these poor
babies are so clueless safe use sites
drugs drugs drugs great these poor
babies they're like maybe if we just
have safe areas for drug use that people
will stop shooting each other where they
got into a fight yeah somebody had a gun
you know yeah that's gonna happen no
matter where that's a fuse no matter
what is well no matter what what does
you have it or not somebody's got a gun
what laws oh yeah well they're they're
they're more like guidelines sure Jess
over the chest no that's not that's not
happening here's they say some members
of the of the chopper have called for
changes to the protest zone following
several shootings over the weekend that
left one person dead and two injured in
an open letter addressed to the chopped
leaders and organizers
of approximately 25 activists and
volunteers proposed changes that include
setting up a safe fuse area on the
outskirts of the occupied area and
creating signage that encourages
intoxicated people to stay away from the
protest zone you know what man
I'm not gonna read this these people are
out of money I get it you want a curfew
that's fine listen yeah I'll tell you
what this kid who's our free thing to
talk to cops probably the right thing
yeah because if he went back in there
and did talk to them he'd be killed oh
did you speak to the the police mate
maybe but no more likely he's go to jail
if he said something yeah there was
right there was a fight that broke out
between proud boys and an tyfa in New
York City okay and they arrested the
proud boys who like I think there wasn't
the proper boys for this the anti-fog
people who got beat up refused to
cooperate with the police and fled the
police then came out later and said if
if they did know who the auntie auntie
four people were they would have
arrested them too
that's why the the far-left just got
away with it yeah so this was a this was
a story in New York where there was an
event held by Pratt boys auntie phone
was surrounding it you you know yelling
stuff the proud boys were leaving see
the auntie four guys and then they you
know run at each other or the proud boys
ran at them they threw a bottle started
fighting proud boys just whomped the
ante for guys hard obviously do these
guys are scrawny you know they're not
gonna be able to defend themselves and
then they the cops showed up the ante
for guys took off yeah wouldn't talk to
the cops and the cops were like it's too
bad only only these guys are going to
prison and the prob was guys would end
up going to prison yeah so anyway they
do to get shot probably the right thing
it's unfortunate I guess because this
place is lawless the wild wild west but
it's it's it does have some laws okay
yeah well he knows the person who shot
him no no no no I'm not talking about
that I'm moving on now talk about the
actual laws oh sure yes see see in the
Chazz if you shoot somebody you get away
with it because normal talk to the cops
right right and also in the Chazz if
you're white you can't go in certain
places yeah because they have certain
areas only for certain races and that
brings us to this one this is a tweet
from Andy no white allies it has been
respectively requested that we leave the
police free zone for a morning and
celebration of the non-white community
from 8 a.m. to 8 p.m. 19 June 2020
please demonstrate your support by
joining us around the barricade white
out there you go Wow and so then not
only do they do the white out they did
the black out took us out zoobi tweeted
white leftists and chest chopped Seattle
protecting the border of a colored only
zone in the name of anti racism because
racial segregation is obviously
progressive yeah right
so this dude Luck's out you can see this
like an Asian woman there's a bunch of
scrawny little white women and then
there it is black out and all black
healing space you know I saw this and
actually if you look I was looking into
the like who's back there
I see white people in there well that's
because they hang out there historically
oppressed oh right that's what she says
yeah she said well if you've been
oppressed then or if it's in your
ancestry then okay so so look clearly
they're doing like the early stages of
segregation yeah they did the farm now
they're doing you know black only spaces
this is completely normal I've seen
stuff happen all the time
what's the next step in California
they're passing that law the are they're
appealing that the Constitution the the
clause in the Constitution that says the
state can't get can't discriminate every
single news story about this is fake
news this is the amazing thing really
when I send it to my friends soon they
do they google search it and what do
they find CNN New York Times you know
Washington Post yeah all saying the bill
stopped affirmative action by repealing
it the state can enact affirmative
action it doesn't actually tell you what
the bill does it's just the title of it
right and so no the press is lying
they're straight up lying it would be
like yeah it's it's it's a weaselly way
of manipulating people into giving up
their civil rights yeah it's crazy
that's what I'm saying the media says
you know we can't imagine this way
imagine if the the a political party
voted to make murder illegal
decriminalize murder straight-up murder
just it's okay premeditated just to kill
yes and then the press reported the bill
that was in place prevented people from
defending themselves in their homes with
this repealing of this bill you will now
be
legally allowed to defend yourself well
yes technically you know you can defend
yourself by taking someone's life if you
have to yeah but it's like if if they
really wanted affirmative action why
would they repeal the whole thing
instead of just adding a clause right
yeah
what's the trajectory of the of the woke
left man yeah I don't think it's gonna I
mean it's gonna hit a wall and the wall
is there they're running full steam
towards the wall I think it was James
Lindsay who tweeted this out he said I
just saw the beginning of the end for
all this nonsense a professional upper
middle class white woman saying wait a
minute you mean my kids are gonna be
disadvantaged just because of the color
of their skin there you go and so I
think it was him or somebody responded
saying these movements always end when
the children of the elites get
threatened now all sudden the fun and
games are over how dare you this was
trying to tell my friend man I was like
you think that if they repeal this law
all of the rich white people are gonna
be alike hey we're good yeah we're not
gonna discriminate you guys go ahead and
do it we won't and I asked her I was
like don't you know there's a ton of
areas of uh of California that I like
extremely racist and she said yes I was
like did you have ever been a Carlsbad
Knight now look with all due respect
Carlsbad all right when I was covering
the droughts in California there were
people in Carlsbad who are complaining
that their their lawns would turn brown
and they should have a right to water
their lawns and we were like you do know
that like a few miles that way they have
no water to drink like maybe you
shouldn't water your lawns and maybe
your lawns will Brown this is drought
what do you expect yeah and they
complained across when I went to Tulare
County yeah it's a rigid there was a
golf course with sprinklers on across
the street literally cross street no
water they were like the families had no
water couldn't shower they had to have
big trucks come in with with non potable
water that you couldn't drink but you
could clean yourself with Wow yeah man
so what do you think happens when you
like wait man these people are nuts
they say that California is you know a
couple years ahead of the rest of us
yeah and then and then they they're
thinking that calc they're gonna pass
this law or the amendment or an
amendment of the amendment I guess yeah
so they're repealing the okay so the the
repealing of the
is gonna happen and they're like yes
everything's gonna be so perfect and
utopia is gonna be achieved and then the
reality is gonna set in of what this
actually means for the people who are a
racist that are sitting there going like
please pass please so we could be racist
maybe that this is not it's not gonna go
over well it's not gonna be this utopia
land where everyone's equal maybe the
Democrats think that now that they
control cancel culture white people will
be too scared to actually implement any
kind of discrimination and they can do
it against whoever they want a lot of
people tweeted when I posted this saying
now they can discriminate against white
people and I'm like no no mr. Ninan to
everybody we talking about yeah yeah
everybody that's that's the point
they're gonna say no Asians they're
gonna say you know Latinos they're gonna
say no to black people it's people
they're gonna choose who they who they
want and you're gonna give them a free
excuse to keep people out for no reason
yeah it's like the elites that have the
power this is basically giving them
ultimate power to be able to just choose
whoever they want to stay in the elite
group as it were you know it's like come
on it's not gonna go over well this is
gonna be this is gonna be bad it's good
you know so I was like talking my friend
about it I said don't you think she
asked me like why all the media
companies are saying it's about
affirmative action and I said maybe
major corporations that are run
predominately by white people are tired
tired of being accused of firing people
based on race and don't to be sued
anymore maybe that's it and now they can
fire whoever they want and no one will
come back and accuse them of racism you
know and if they do they'll say so it's
legal yeah I'm allowed to fire you oh
yes straight up they don't they don't
think about it they don't read the bills
they don't know it's really hard to have
conversations with people like this man
because it's like when I'm talking a lot
of my friends online they're the
knowledge gap is so intense that it's
almost impossible to actually explain
things to them so like you know I'll
talk to one of my friends about say the
Tom cotton op-ed yeah you know he's so
he write an op-ed saying the
insurrection act we should come in and
with a show force to stop the riots and
if they don't know anything about that
yeah all they know is like my one friend
was like oh wasn't it like a really
really awful article so like it was like
everyone hated it not like no that's not
no that's not the case at all wait did
that actually happen yeah yeah yeah and
so it's like listen if you're only
hearing scuttlebutt because you don't
read the news
your progressive friends are telling you
they wrote a really racist awful article
and so I haven't got mad if you actually
pay attention what's going on the
majority of registered voters in this
country the majority of people in this
country supported the National Guard
coming in to stop the rioting so this
was a popular op-ed shut down by zealots
and the dude who worked for the New
Times had to resign over it so yeah man
there's a lot of reasons why they want
to repeal civil rights law huh the
fallout from this reminds me a little
bit of what happened with a b5 so they
were like we have this great intention
we're gonna make it better for gig
workers we're gonna put this bill into
place and what worker Oh gig workers
people and they put into place and
they're like all the journalists are
fired all the freelance writers are
fired and that's something they'd not
even thought about so they don't think
past stage one in California it's not
even it's not even about like just the
writers there are a lot of people who
did a lot of temporary work that have
been fired straight up contracts
terminated California man is going to
become a nightmare State yeah it's like
dude you're right it is a nightmare
State I'm not gonna go back man I'm I'm
not gonna set foot in that place yeah it
feels like they've been living in a
bubble and and everyone in California is
in their own little different bubble and
all the bubbles are popped at once and
we're gonna see it hasn't it hasn't
happened yet but there's still a few
bubbles out there but California is an
experiment in what happens when you when
stupid people protest there's a lot of
smart people ofor Nia right but look at
her leaving it's not it's not even so
much of necessarily about if they're
stupid or not you look at celebrities
who don't care yeah they'll just say
whatever they think is popular yeah
they're tearing responsibility yeah yes
I take responsibility yeah in your
million-dollar mansion what does that
mean you're gonna whip yourself you see
that video of the self-flagellation I
can't believe that I don't know if they
were actually hitting themselves but but
a bunch of people apparently this was a
Ian Miles Chong tree inside I have no
idea was this from but a bunch of dude
white dudes showed up with
self-flagellation marks that's when you
take the chain with like the blade and
you whack yourself in the back with
ah in like penance to your religion dude
these people have gone full-on zealot
fanaticism man you know their backs are
covered in it maybe it's cosmetic mate
but no but maybe it was makeup maybe I
hope so but one it could be I think the
most likely thing is makeup I don't
think they're actually gonna whack
themselves with with you know blades or
chainsaw they're they're trolling it was
it was people pretending it was black
people pretending to be slave owners
holding a sign saying what if this was
your history Wow and then funny enough a
bunch of black lives matter people
started yelling at him like what are you
doing you people are crazy yeah dude
the what weren't you telling me about
there's like a video from a dude from
black lives matter who's at the far left
took it over and they went nuts yep
what was that it was from like three
years ago damn two and a half years ago
or something I don't exactly remember
but he was basically like yeah I
couldn't be a part of that anymore I I
didn't know where the finances were
going I was a big part of it for a long
time and every single time we try to do
anything someone would be there to steer
it in a direction that wasn't what I
believe yep it's like that's what was in
the easiest way to explain it I say look
at what Dave Chappelle said and his
special had nothing to do with taxes or
communism or or equity you know I was
literally talking about people who are
mad that people were dying and we're
getting violent because of it right his
view of what the problem is is in a
different reality to what these actual
protesters are doing what they're
demanding so you there was recently a
viral video where some woman from black
lives matter I I'm in fact at this so
you got a fact check me on this one
where she said she was a trained Marxist
you saw that you know who she was I
thought I saw a man that was a different
leader black lives matter saying the
same thing yeah okay you guys know the
history of people who follow the Marxist
Marx was a racist wasn't yeah yeah I
mean it's funny that they're like
tearing down statutes cuz they're racist
there's a comic and it's uh it's it's a
tearing down of Washington but it's a
wheel and it switches to Marx uh-huh and
I saw some it supposed to be critical
right of it but then I saw someone post
on Facebook and they were like this is
uncritically like ironically
awesome and I was like marks it's like
famously racist wasn't he like needed
not like Jews oh really no he actually
really didn't like people yeah he wrote
like a cancelled yep cancel marks and
yet they're they're worshiping him no
yeah
what does go because it's all lies bro
yeah that's why that dude was was pissed
that's why you have these these women
from black lives matter yelling at the
dudes who have their backs all whipped
up right you know man I wonder if the
the big non-binary push for like Gen Z
is just an excuse to give them some kind
of identity so they can claim to be
oppressed good point because like it's
like you can add you can be gay you can
be you can like whoever you want it like
no one cares anymore yeah like you you
can like whoever you want it's like
they're like whatever it's like with
that Justin roiland show what is that
where's that show called of aliens one
yes solar opposites where she's trying
desperately to light oh my god love that
because she's trying to find someone who
won't accept her because she's a woman
she's but there's no one like that she
tried to create an all-boys book club
and all the boys showed up to tell her
what a misogynist she was for not
inviting girls and she's like wait guys
but when when she tried saying I need
this for my class they attacked her
right and call her mom and they chased
after yeah yeah it was such a good
example of like what these people do
yeah like when you see a bunch of white
people scream at Candace Owens and call
her like a white supremacist I'm like
dude you guys are living in bizarro
world
there's so many it doesn't feel like
there's a lot of them that they just
don't want to live they don't want to
realize reality
yeah isn't what they're actually living
in these are the conversation man listen
like I've tried having conversations
with people about this stuff and the the
progressive like leftist identitarian
people have this view it's III compare
it to like a digital versus an analogue
view of things you know analog you have
the wave it's a gradient it's it's it's
not just one or is it one or zero yeah
but they view things as either like
you're oppressed or you're not and so so
they think you have the oppressed box
and they're not a press box binary and
so right absolutely binary
so when I say something like my family
faced depression they go but you look
white enough so not oppressed yeah
and I'm like but you just erased my
entire history family existence and
right and they're like and honestly
anyone because anyone can go through
like situations where they are oppressed
it doesn't matter where your heritage is
it's all about the situation you're in
so well so actually had a really really
good argument against leftist
identitarian ISM first and foremost is
there a historical gap due to racism
100% definitely institutional racism
still exists in a lot of forms slavery
is still existing but right now check it
out that it's like that exists in on
this planet still in America we had
racist laws going back a long time even
if the nineteen blockbusting didn't end
until the 80s I believe yeah so the way
I try to explain systemic racism is you
create a bunch of laws that are racist
and you put people in this really you
know negative position because of it
once they're in the position you then
change the laws and say okay nothing's
racist anymore but now they're in a hole
they can't climb out of because you
throw em in there in the first place
however I've never been a fan like I
think I think I align my views with like
brett weinstein on this one but i could
be wrong i want to misquote you Brett um
but he mentioned that the solutions are
class-based not race-based and that's
always been my position yeah we've
talked about that many times on the show
but i had a really good argument against
everything the left is trying to say
with like you know reparations and you
know focusing on black lives there you
know they need it more than anyone else
my first point is how do you quantify
oppression like you know that's that's
that's the joke like good question you
know it's a it's a black Jewish
paraplegic you know differently abled in
a wheelchair like like you're really
gonna play the oppression Olympics
determine who gets what access to what
but I told my friend I was like what you
got to understand about when you say it
should be for black people only is that
because of progressives people like
Bernie Sanders
we have Loving v Virginia a ruling from
the Supreme Court in 1967 that said
interracial marriage and cohabitation is
legal now you know that means we have
like two or three generations
of race-mixing in this country and if
you now want to start quantifying your
laws based on black white you know
Mexican or whatever you are basically
rewinding the clock to a point where
you're telling all the people who are
mixed-race that they're out yeah they
don't have the white privilege but they
also don't get any of the new privileges
either it's ridiculous so that's the
best way I can say like here's why your
your plan makes no sense it doesn't work
you create a black only space how do you
deal with your policies and your you
know your vision of a future creating a
generation of people now who you're
planning to oppress you can't do it you
got it you got a new minority group that
doesn't fall into your brackets of Asian
or or you know african-american or
whatever exactly it could be it could be
both it could be non it could be you
know people can lie so how about we do
class-based cuz you can't lie about how
much money yet oh well you can but I
guess but they can they can you have to
prove you know income and stuff proving
your racial oppression is impossible I
agree but I mean the other big things
obvious is like are we gonna give Will
Smith's kids a grant like here's money
Will Smith's kids who are millionaires
right no that makes no sense thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you